[Applause]
yes there was an Insurrection yesterday
I have no problem calling it an
Insurrection because that's what they've
called everything that anyone who they
don't like uh does uh here is video of
the DC Capital
[Music]
[Applause]
yesterday
all right so there's obviously way more
video there's plenty of people being
arrested and everything else but in
essence they storm the capital I see
virtually no difference between this and
January 6 or anything else we do know
that the one difference will be how they
treat these people um Ben before we get
into the Hamas caucus specifically and
and Rashida uh who I think I think has
taken over from AOC as the the lead
General on that thing are you amazed how
quickly they flipped BLM into a pramas
movement I mean it seems like they just
have a switch and when they want to turn
on these Clon soldiers they can just
send them out and they'll do whatever
they want well again that's the beauty
of the intersectional Coalition I mean
why why would you possibly think that
BLM would suddenly flip in favor of
Kamas and the answer is because there's
a back scratching deal if you support
our cause we'll support your cause our
cause is really all the same which is
hatred of the West I mean that that's
really what all this comes down to
Israel is just in Emissary of the West
in this particular Viewpoint it's it's
it's not even that Israel is a place of
particular hatred it's sort of the tip
of the spear it's the canary and the
coine as people like to say but but it's
it's not as though they hate Israel sort
of only that that Israel is the only
point of contention Israel is just the
most convenient point of contention and
the place where they can also build the
largest Coalition because again Israel
is Jewish and there are a lot of people
who really really hate Jews there's only
one state on Earth where people actually
require it to consistently explain its
own existence that is the state of
Israel it's the only place on Earth
Earth where where people demand
justification for why there's a Jewish
State there are 55 Islamic States no one
has ever asked why Pakistan an Islamic
State or or Afghanistan or Iran or Iraq
or any of these other any of the other
country so they're picking a convenient
point of uh of of sort of Coalition and
coalescing but yes I mean it it flips it
flips purposes it goes directly from
rallies about trans women our women to
this in like a heartbeat and it's and
it's amazing it's the exact same people
they just they just take off their
t-shirt put on a new t-shirt and then
and then go to the capital building and
make trouble like this so yeah I mean
that that that's that's the entire
coalitional deal again not a shock it's
why that Harvard student letter that had
33 organizations on it including things
like the pan pan Asian-American
Coalition why do you think they're on
there you think they care about this
they don't care about this but they're
part of the same
Coalition yeah it's so psycho it's like
psychotic and also obvious which is a
weird combination I
suppose